ونعود الى ابرز التطورات في مسار التحقيق
في انفجار مرفا بيروت والذي حدث يوم
الرابع من اغسطس 2020 والحق دمار ضخما في
المرفقه والاحياء القريبه منه واسفر عن
سقوطي اكثر من 200 215 قتيلا
وسته الاف وخمسمائه بعد يومين زار الرئيس
الفرنسيما والمكرون بيروت ودعى الى تحقيق
دولي في التفجير وهو ما رفضته السلطات
اللبنانيه وبعد اربعه ايام من الانفجار
تظهر الاف اللبنانيين ضد المسؤولين
السياسيين بعد ما حملوهم مسؤوليه الماساه
فيما اعلن رئيس الحكومه حسان دياب استقاله
حكومته في العاشر من اغسطس
انا في العاشر من ديسمبر 2020 فدعى المحقق
العدلي في قضيه الانفجار فادي صوان على
حسان دياب وثلاثه وزراء سابقين بتهمه
الاهمال والتقصير
والتسبب بوفاه وجرحي الاف الاشخاص اما في
الثامن عشر من فبراير 2021 تم التنحيته
صوان من منصبه وعين طارق البيطار خلف له
في الثاني من يوليو 2021 اعلن المحقق
العدليه الجديد عزمه على استجواب دياب
تزامنا مع اطلاقه مسار للدعاء على عدد من
الوزراء السابقين وعلى مسؤولين امينه
وعسكريين
تمام تعليق والتحقيق الانفجار اربع مرات
جراء دعوى قدمت ضد المحقق العدلي اخرها في
الثالث والعشرين من ديسمبر 2021
وينضم الان الينا من بيروت الكاتبه صحفي
والمحلل السياسي ابراهيم حيدر استاذ
ابراهيم اهلا بك اذا مسار يعني فيه كثير
من المواقف اللافته الان
حيث نقص الان في هذا التوقيت كيف يمكن وصف
الملف
نعم تحيه لك ااا
الواقع ان هذا المسار هو مسار معقد
ومتشابك على مختلف المستويات يعني تدخل
فيه عناصر او عوامل سياسيه واخرى قضائيه
مختلفه يعني
انطلاقا من ان المحقق العادلي عاده الى
استئناف التحقيق في انفجار مرفا بيروت همم
بعد ثلاثه عشر شهرا من تلقيفه او وقفه عن
العمل او كف يده عن العمل وبالتالي هو
استند الى
همم
مرجعيه همم دستوريه او نص دستوري في هذا
السياق واعتبر ان المجلس العدلي هو المقرر
في هذا الشهر وهو السلطه العليا التي هي
الوحيده التي تتمكن من اما تنحيته او رده
عن متابعه التحقيقات لا شك ان المشار
المعقد سيكون امام طارق البيطار لانه همم
البلد كله هو ياتي في هو يعود في دول
انقسام سياسي حاد وخلافات سياسيه كبيره
وشهور رئاسي وفراغ متعدد المستويات وان
انهيار على همم مختلف هذا خصوصا في شان
الاقتصادي والمالي وبالتالي هناك تشاؤلات
كثيره حول همم
هذا القاضي همم ان يستانف او ان يصل الى
القرار الاتهامي النهائي بعد ثلاثه عشر
شهرا من توقفه عن التحقيقات وهذه همم يعني
عامل قطع كبير يعني في مسار التحقيقات
وبالتالي صغرى لا يمكن تجوزها بهذه
الشهوله
الوضع الاقتصادي السيء الذي يمر به لبنان
حاليا والغضب العام والاستياء العام على
الصعيد الشعبي هل هذا الاستياء كافي ربما
لدفع المسار الى الامام هذه المره في حين
تعثر في مرات سابقه
نعم هناك همم احتمالات كثيره يمكن همم
توضع همم
امامنا ولكن لا يبدو ان هناك همم يعني رغم
كل هذا همم
الشعبي لا يبدو ان هناك حركه فعليه يمكن
ان تشكل دافعا او رافع عليه ان كان في
مجال التحقيق او ان كان في مجال همم
استعاده المؤسسات همم السياسيه والدستوريه
دورها في البلد يعني هناك مخاوف فعليه في
دول هذا الفراغ والانهيار ان يذهب البلد
الى نوع من الفوضى او همم انفجار اهلي همم
كل العوامل باتت يعني همم مهيا لهذا همم
لهذا الواقع او لهذه الفوضى بالتالي نحن
امام يعني اعتقد ان امام مشكله همم
متعدده همم المستويات مشكله سياسيه كبرى
لا شك ان عوده همم
سيكون لها
وهي بدات يعني من خلال همم استدعائي
لرئيس الحكومه السابق
وقاده اجهزه امنيه كبار يعني
ولديهم تغطيات سياسيه في هذا اسيا ايضا
يعني هناك انقسام قضائي واضح في في هذا
الشان هناك النيابه العامه التمييزيه ترفض
همم القرارات التي اتخذها ترفض اصلا عوده
البيطار الى ممارسه مهماته التحقيقيه في
همم انفجار ما الفرق بيروت يعني مشهد مخيف
على مختلف المستويات همم يمكن ان يضع كثير
من التساؤلات وعلامات الاستفهام حول همم
قدرت يعني القاضي في ظل هذا المناخ
السياسيه على استكمال تحقيقاته والوصول
الى قرار اتهامي همم فعلي من دون همم
تدخلات سياسيه ما في هذا السؤال اذا كانت
هذه التساؤلات هذه المره ستحصل على اجابات
اشكرك جزيلا همم ابراهيم حيدر من بيروت
شكرا لك